this is lucy james reading for reviewer
alessandro barbosa ever since the launch
of the nintendo switch in 2017 the
perception of what a handheld gaming
device can be has changed there's been
an explosion of similarly compact pc
devices released lately each with mixed
results while there are great devices
out there now such as the ir neo pro
they're still limited by the
capabilities of mobile hardware while
also costing a lot more than its
performance suggests however valve's
steam deck addresses both pitfalls
entirely with cutting-edge hardware
thoughtfully designed ergonomics a
satisfying controller layout and a
software layer that simplifies pc gaming
the steam deck makes it a breeze to link
to your steam account and get started
with your library on the go better yet
it comes in at a reasonable price
starting at 400 and reaching only 650
for its highest tier model essentially
half the price of its closest
competitors the steam deck's design is
as impressive as it is massive with the
entire device coming in wider taller and
thicker than the nintendo switch this
allows the steam deck to pack in a
larger display with the 1200 by 807 inch
display which offers vivid color
reproduction while also giving you ample
brightness control for gaming in
numerous environments the bezels are on
the thick side with the two on the left
and right of the screen specifically
wasteful of space but it's a small price
to pay for a display of this quality
flanking the display are two thumb
sticks and two touch pads with the
former being one of the steam deck's
strongest pieces of hardware these thumb
sticks feel remarkable while also being
comfortable and accurate
the tops of the thumb sticks are also
tiny touch pads too allowing for some
fancy software controller configurations
the ability to activate gyro assisted
aiming while your thumb is on the right
stick for example is a small but
immensely useful detail the two touch
pads beneath the sticks are less
impressive but no less useful letting
you play games that require mouse input
relatively easily their tactile
vibration as you move your finger across
them adds accuracy to your input with
software configuration letting you alter
this response to help you better feel
the ends of each pad with the force of
the haptics rather than just feeling
your finger slide off entirely both the
d-pad and the four face buttons are
pushed out to the edges of the steam
deck which can look odd on first
inspection the overall sculpt of the
steam deck also naturally places your
hands close to each of them however
meaning you likely won't be adjusting
your grip or reaching out in
uncomfortable ways to hold these buttons
when holding the auspiciously large
device the thickness of the steam deck
and its curved back mitigates a lot of
its size and weight when you're holding
it avoiding the vice grip you need to
comfortably hold other thinner devices
of this ilk the steam deck's cooling is
also exceptional there's a single
exhaust on the back of the steam deck
and another on the top both of which
push out enough air to keep the steam
deck cool under stressful loads the fans
are not too loud but their pitch is
quite high which prevents them from
disappearing into the background
rounding out the inputs are the digital
shoulder buttons and analog triggers
each of which features a satisfying
little rumble at the end of each press
four programmable grip buttons also sit
inside an area where your index middle
and ring fingers will naturally rest
making them easily accessible you can
make use of the steam deck's bluetooth
capabilities to connect other wireless
controllers which might be required if
you're playing while connected to an
external monitor it could also give you
a break from holding the device if you
simply want to prop it up and continue
enjoying the deck's great screen and
surprisingly powerful front-facing
speakers both of which can get
incredibly loud without losing much of
their detail the only big miss in terms
of hardware on the steam deck is the
device's rumble which lacks the fidelity
required to really accentuate actions
within your games the vibration isn't
refined enough to make distinguishing
between left and right sides of the
device well it's rather weak overall and
is certainly one facet that could be
improved on if any future revisions of
the steam deck are planned the attention
to detail doesn't stop in the steam deck
software steamos which sits on top of
linux is very similar to steam's big
picture mode on desktops giving you a
console like experience when navigating
through your steam library but offering
certain customization options that
remind you that you're ultimately still
on a highly pliable pc your entire
existing steam library can be viewed on
the steam deck but not every game will
be playable steam os features a filter
that lets you view games that have been
deck verified by valve to be compatible
with the steam deck while also achieving
various quality checks having this
filter lets you quickly get going with a
game that will show off the device in
its best light but it doesn't mean the
rest of your library won't work some
games miss out on some of the quality
checks which puts them in a playable but
not necessarily fully supported category
some games such as the witcher 3 wild
hunt are categorized like this purely
because of in-game text that might be
too small on the native display but
otherwise runs just fine on the hardware
in addition to these two categories
valve also labels games it hasn't tested
yet as unknown which may or may not work
as well as unsupported for games that do
not run on the steam deck every vr game
falls under this category but numerous
multiplayer titles do too especially
those with easy anti-cheat support that
is still being regularly updated to
support proton games such as apex
legends rust and pubg are all unplayable
because of this so your mileage for
multiplayer gaming on the steam deck
will vary at launch steamos features a
handful of system level tools to help
you optimize your balance of performance
and battery life depending on the games
you're playing there are options that
let you lock the frame rate to 30 frames
per second reduce the total tdp that the
steam deck can operate at and set a
maximum gpu clock speed a performance
overlay is also available to let you
monitor cpu and gpu usage power draw
frame rates and frame times and more
giving you a bit of insight into how
your games are running in real time if
you're making use of the steamdex
microsd slot to expand your storage you
can set either of the steam deck's
internal memory or the microsd card as a
default install location as well as
easily move games between the two i
ended up repurposing a sd card
previously used in a nintendo switch and
found there to be a noticeable
difference in loading times between the
two for some games and near negligible
differences for others moving games
between the internal ssd and microsd
card was also a slow process lasting
anywhere between 20 to 45 minutes
depending on the size of the game
perhaps one of the biggest incentives
for regular pc gamers to invest in a
steam deck is the ability to seamlessly
take your game from one platform to
another with steam having supported
cloud saves for years now it's no
surprise that this feature works pretty
well when moving between another pc and
the steam deck this comes in handy if
you're wanting to take your game over to
another display without moving your
entire pc but the performance of the
steam deck is less impressive when
moving away from its native resolution
even at 1080p the steam deck struggles
to cope with the increased demand on
most modern titles which should be
evident based on how they perform
natively the one benefit is that
connecting to an external display is
easy with the usbc hub even without
valve's first party dock which is coming
this spring one improvement to deck
verified titles or those that might be
updated to perform better on the
portable device would be the ability to
install assets specific to its use case
many games such as do maternal and
fallout 4 feature massive installation
sizes in part due to their high
resolution assets taking up precious
space do maternal takes up nearly 100
gigabytes alone for example another
omission is the ability to continue
downloading games while the steam deck
is suspended once put to sleep the steam
deck terminates its internet connection
pausing any downloads you might have had
going after confirming with valve this
is expected behavior meaning you'll need
to have the steam deck screen on and the
device's fans going even if you're just
downloading new games to play
given how many different games you can
play on the steam deck at launch and
with 6 gigabytes of vram and 16
gigabytes of system ram there's plenty
of room for top tier experiences to work
such as god of war the recent hitman
trilogy and dark souls 3 to name just a
few an early indicator of just how well
the steam deck can perform came with god
of war which not long ago really pushed
the limits of both the ps4 and ps4 pro
running the game at its original
settings preset the steam deck was able
to deliver a smooth 30 frames per second
across some taxing sections including
the physics heavy duel with balder in
the game's opening this is essentially
the same game that required a much
larger immobile console to play at a
similar quality level just a handful of
years ago so it feels a bit like magic
to have it in the palm of your hands
today
the witcher 3 wild hunt show that this
level of performance can't always be
expected to scale in a linear manner
however while holding a solid 30 frames
per second seemed fine the game's framed
times were all over the place creating a
lot of judder that rendered it nearly
unplayable this unevenness wasn't
present in cd projekt red's latest title
cyberpunk 2077
using the game's new built-in benchmark
i was able to achieve an average frame
rate above 30 frames per second with a
mixture of medium and low settings while
traversing night city felt remarkably
smooth once i had kept the frame rate
resident evil village was even more
impressive the game's default settings
consistently ran between 50 to 60 frames
only wavering from a locked 60 frames
per second when i was outdoors exploring
the semi-open world this is a game that
is barely a year old running better than
it did on most older consoles which
certainly shows the potential for what a
game making good use of proton can do
running these graphically intensive
games comes at a cost however firstly
the already audible fans ramp up even
more loud enough to be heard over the
steam deck's remarkable front-facing
speakers battery life also takes a
substantial hit with many of the games
i've talked about driving down the steam
deck's estimated play time to just about
under two hours
where valve gets its two to eight hour
battery estimate is down to which games
you choose to play spelunky two ran at a
buttery smooth 60 frames per second and
bumped up battery life estimations into
six hour territory celeste pushed this
up even further getting closer to
valve's eight hour maximum estimation in
many ways this is where the steam deck
shines there's a very clear market for
the steam deck it's a device purpose
built for a selection of people that
already have established steam libraries
and simply want the most convenient and
performant way to continue those games
away from a desktop it's also an
affordable way to start building a new
steam library too with an easy to
navigate interface and enough system
level information provided by valve to
discern which games will work and which
won't while it isn't enough to replace a
bigger and less mobile pc the steam deck
excels at being a mobile hub for your
steam games giving you enough to work
with to get the best out of a selection
of games you can't go without while away
from your desktop in that regard there
simply is nothing better on the market
right now
you